nice to see you you too last time I saw
you was our Google Hangout that's right
we were hanging out with Mr O'Brien Mr
Wilson and a bunch of other people and
it was uh nice to see you in in person
yeah this is crazy it was a little
Google Hangout and I think you guys are
making fun of me because my room was
completely bare only supportive I think
there was did you not take that as a
support system I think he wasn't making
fun of me really I got to change that
tape in fact I like to broker something
if I could if you would like to intern
as an interior designer maybe you could
throw up a couple of photos it wouldn't
be the worst thing there you go I will
do that I will be an intern for Justine
and I will Design uh your apartment
that's what I'm going to do I have like
a little plant fake thing here no that's
going to go I'm getting I'm getting rid
of that that was intended only as as
playful support it was great though but
I mean trust me don't worry it's usually
a disaster because that's where I shoot
everything at so well I think it's
impressive I think I don't know if all
the viewers know that but you actually
shoot and then you you edit and you put
the stuff together yourself right yeah
so I'm going to take all this footage
from our cameras here this is a this is
a one woman show which is impressive
it's fun I also brought a little game
here we this is not a little game I know
this game Operation so you know how this
is played right I do and I've been
playing it quite a bit lately because I
have uh a nephew and nieces and Friends
With Kids I have a lot of little kids
around and what I've learned is the
passion I had for the game younger does
not match my ineptness today there's
something about being older when you're
little and you got little hands these
kids can get in there like nobody's
business but I've struggled I've I've
struggled very badly in the game don't
think I'm going to back down I need this
in my life I need to be a part of
operation I'm just letting you know I I
I don't feel that I'm a world class how
have you been so far um not very good
okay well let's turn that around right
now so you go first okay all right here
we go so you have to turn it on I think
yeah just whichever one the nose went
red so that must mean it's on so yeah I
mean we also talk about Pittsburgh too
cuz I'm you're from Pittsburgh and my
friend Steve Burn is from Pittsburgh
he's a stand up comedian and we have a
show on on TBS that's set in Pittsburgh
called Sullivan and Son okay so now I
should have you actually been to
Pittsburgh I have been to Pittsburgh but
my friend takes me there every day when
a Pittsburgh team is playing because he
is fanatical all I'm hearing about
lately is the uh Penguins they've been
doing really well too team you can try
to throw me off as part of the game okay
now see I set the bar low but I got a I
got a a rubber wait so now I have to go
we're playing is for real I don't know
if it's for real but I think we can keep
the conversation and we can operate on
this man right something point of
interest for this man to be operated on
he's kind of a will right because it's
not like I'm not trying to move it on
you but he has what does he have cell
phones and rubber bands that's right
this is not like real body parts I'm
sweating okay there we go you should be
sweating this man put his put his uh put
his cardboard body in literally in your
hands he shouldn't do that and you just
remove something from him that could be
considered to be hazardous now should I
go after something more challenging um
maybe how about you try the cell phone
where's the cell phone located it's uh
it's on his hand that's a tough one yeah
that's a tough one I know I'm trying to
throw you off here I don't mind being
thrown off okay okay so I'm going to
start asking you some rapid fire
questions you can ask me rapid fire
question okay so what's your favorite
color my favorite color changes M yours
purple that's a great color yeah it is
it's also Justin Bieber's favorite color
are you a prince fan um so I go Prince
should go Bieber yeah what oh that's
okay that's what makes the uh world go
around I can't believe what's happening
and I'm not I'm I'm I didn't lowball you
this is amazing you know what it is what
cuz it's about this guy's life it's not
about me it's not about my hands anymore
it is on I'm letting you know so scar
right yeah this is about him this isn't
about me this isn't about when it when
it comes to A Moment Like This where the
cardboard guy needs the cell phone out
of him that's when I come alive yeah
let's see what you got okay I'm going to
go for one I'm going to do it the other
way I'm going to support you in this
moment okay thank
you you can do this thank you oh God oh
God come here you little frog okay he
said D he can't hear you so you can talk
to that's good yes good okay here you go
you want to try another one well I don't
know should we quit while we're ahead or
what do you think I don't know we'll do
one more and see how this works so the
internship it's a little movie that you
you guys just did you shot this last
summer correct that's right and now it's
out true and you know it's been really
nice the audience has just been
responding unbelievable to the movie and
I and I think it's really because the
movie is really about something the
movie is very funny but it's it's really
also kind of about when things come kind
of uh are hard or kind of aren't working
out when you have to sort of try to
persevere not thear from this game
that's right and I'm going for this I'm
going for the toilet can't have a toilet
in his stomach it's just not healthy not
working he said is it okay to walk
around I said we got a toilet's got to
come out today bro this is not working
out now I'm really excited to see it
especially cuz I do remember the
flashbacks of being an intern and the
struggles man there were the struggle
was real that's right want you were
really were an intern you had struggles
I did I like the way Google does it
because they have people really jump in
and and work on the teams for real it's
not like they have people going to get
dry cleaning yeah know that's is that
what you did I didn't I was actually
coding HTML oh that's interesting that's
right so was very scary because you talk
about those things at all not in my head
like I'm I'm with that that's right back
in the day that toilet's a rough one but
you know what I I he's going to be a
better without it but this game used to
shake and just it was a lot more
interactive and scary when I was younger
you hitting the things a lot young maybe
I don't know you maybe I'll bring you in
maybe I'll bring you in on the same one
we'll take turns I'm going to take this
one out and then cuz I don't I didn't
hit the sides actually let's just see
what happens when we hit the sides
that's terrible I don't like it it
happens it scares me yeah it's that's
that's the deterrent that's what you
strive not to have happen well thank you
so much for chatting with me well it's
wonderful to chat with you I think that
he's he's healthier I'm sorry we didn't
complete all the operations it was
really hard but I'm glad that at least
we got a cell phone out of him and um he
seems to be smiling more
so um our work here is done thank you
and you thank you so
much